- [Instructor] Tomas dropped
off two packages to be shipped.
One package weighed 1.38 kilograms,
and the other package weighed 720 grams.
So the first one they give in kilograms,
and the second one they give us in grams.
What was the combined weight
of both packages in grams?
So what I wanna do is, I'm
gonna convert both of these
to grams, and then add 'em up
to get the combined weight.
Well, we already know the
second one is 720 grams,
but what's the first
one in terms of grams?
Well, let's see, 1.38,
I could write kilograms like that.
Well, if one kilogram is 1,000 grams,
and that's what the prefix
kilo means, it means 1,000,
well, to go from one to
1.38, I'm multiplying
by 1.38,
so I'm also, if I want
it in terms of grams,
I'll take 1,000 grams
and multiply by 1.38.
So this is going to be 1,000 times 1.38
is 1,380 grams,
which I could've just denoted with a G,
but now let's add those together.
This is the first package,
and then the second package
is 720 grams,
and so if I were to add,
this is going to be,
let's see, got a zero,
10,
well let's see, four plus seven is 11,
and then one plus one is two.
We get 2,100 grams in total.
Let's do another one of these
unit conversion examples.
Julia and her friends are
making kites out of paper.
For each kite, they need a piece of paper
that is 0.65 meters wide.
How many centimeters, how
many centimeters of paper
will they need to make four kites?
So they tell us how wide the paper
is in meters for each kite,
but they want the answer in centimeters,
and they want it for four kites.
So, let's think about this a little bit.
Each kite is 0.65 meters,
0.65 meters.
So to go from one to 0.65,
you'd multiply by 0.65
on the meters,
and so to go to 100 centimeters
to the number of
centimeters you would need
for the width of a kite, you'd similarly
multiply by 0.65.
Well, 65 hundredths times 100
is going to be 65,
65 centimeters per kite.
So this 0.65 meters wide per kite,
in centimeters it is 65 centimeters.
Now, they don't want just how much paper
will they need to make one kite,
they want four kites.
So we would multiply this times four.
This is how much we need per kite,
so let's multiply that times four.
And so let's see, four times five is 20.
Four times six is 24,
plus two is 26.
260 centimeters of paper
for the width of the four kites.
Let's do one more of these.
This is a volume conversion.
Omar is pouring five liters of water
into two goldfish bowls.
He spills 200 milliliters of water,
and then divides the
remaining water evenly
between the two bowls.
How many milliliters of water
does Omar pour into each bowl?
So we want our answer at
the end in milliliters,
and so let's just convert the amount
that he starts with into milliliters.
So he starts with five,
he starts with five liters.
So how many milliliters
is that going to be?
Well, they tell us one
liter is 1,000 milliliters,
so if we have five liters,
we're multiplying our quantity times five,
that's gonna be five
times, it's going to be
five times as many milliliters,
so that's 1,000 times
five is 5,000 milliliters,
so that's what he starts with.
Now, before he splits
this 5,000 milliliters
between these two bowls,
he spills 200 milliliters,
so let's subtract out what he spills,
'cause he, that's not going
to be able to be split.
Milliliters.
And so, that's going to give us,
so we're gonna have 4,800 milliliters
to split between those two bowls,
and so each bowl, that's what they ask us,
how many milliliters of water
does he pour into each bowl?
Well, see, if he's gonna
split this into two bowls,
each bowl's gonna get half of this,
and so each bowl is going
to get half of 4,800,
so we just divide that by two,
so each bowl is going to
get 2,400 milliliters,
2,400 milliliters and 2,400 milliliters.
That's how much each bowl is going,
that's how much Omar is
going to pour into each bowl.